j y lee arrived at court
not knowing if he would be able to walk
free again
as head of south korea's biggest
conglomerate
business groups had appealed for
leniency and samsung
itself has argued that lee is essential
to its day-to-day running
a claim disputed by critics of the
so-called che
ball system of family-run businesses
that still
dominates the economy here every day
operation is done by the professional
managers so even in the jail
usually the the control of korean jabber
has full information provided by the old
his staff and even in the jail and he or
she can make
a proper decision making in 2017
lee was found guilty of bribing
disgraced
former president park yong hey and her
long-time associate
choi sun sil to allow the smooth
transition of power at
samsung from his father he was released
after one year of a five-year prison
sentence
the prosecution appealed and last year
lee promised changes in his company's
business practices
in a bid to stay out of prison
we failed to live up to public
expectations we caused disappointment
because we did not strictly uphold the
law
at ethical standards with the power
of south korea's chaebol system under
scrutiny
samsung agreed to set up a compliance
committee last year at the request of
the court
to look into its business practices to
ensure a case like this wouldn't happen
again
it was widely seen as a bid to please
the court
ahead of this ruling but it wasn't
enough
and the court ordered lee back into
custody ruling he'd concealed his
multi-million dollar bribe
and also committed perjury in his
explanation about it to the national
assembly
rob mcbride al jazeera seoul